si vous n'étiez pas là dans le before
c'est vrai que christophe nous a dit
j'adore la cambrure de nadège surtout
qu'on pourrait presque y poser un verre
elle nous a dit quelqu'un déjà poser un
verre quand je me mets comme ceux ci
c'est ce qu'on pourrait poser un
jerrican c'est pas un verre alors
puisque on a nous réparer sachant que si
le ver ne tient pas il se renversera sur
une auréole sur les fesses pendant toute
l'émission de ça mais ça ferait du
fraysse est prête attention
vous sonnez il écope de bouger
d'accord car c'est le grand cabaret que
nous faisons ce soir va récupérer le
versant les mains et le boire écrit à
tort je regardais ce numéro regardez
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
christophe ça va bouger
oui
christophe est très rapidement sort un
livre aujourd'hui voilà donc oui bon on
va passer très rapidement de sucre et
saufs carrière parce que ça s'appelle
c'est pas grave ça va pas durer dit son
éditeur est il à l'infini le contrat
voilà
et d'ailleurs pour assurer la promotion
christophe des là vous allez maintenant
faire le tour du plateau avec le livre
sur la tête sans qu'il tombe car les
numéros
il va pas tomber vous avez le devoir de
tous de faire la promo qui ne t'ont pas
[Applaudissements]
oui voilà une belle histoire d'amour
dans la hollandaise
13 déjà on va vous applaudir très fort
[Applaudissements]
on est monté sur mon dos car à numéros
et à la brosse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous allons faire le vieux chalet le
vieux-hull et le mieux cela
[Applaudissements]
vous restez immobile et puis vous avez
droit de dormir de toute façon c'est un
peu ce que vous faites attention vous ne
bougez plus vous dormez et là vous
essayez d'en empiler
non mais oh là là là encore quand même
on n'est pas censé pour le réveiller il
y en a il y en a deux noms mais il y en
a trois
sinon j'en fais un côté web était à côté
séchage déjà qu'à aplatir et mettez lui
sur son gros cul et il y en a trois et
ça marche pas très bien votre histoire
et c'est super dur c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs ceux qui ont été sélectionnés
sauf top bougeait plus oui car c'est
vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]